I want to talk about the greatest acting
performance of all time and it's in one
scene and I can't believe I've never
talked about this before Nicholas Cage
when he goes sup
you know that scene oh my god dude I'm
looking this up
Nicholas Cage sup dude he keeps saying
Sup in this I'm just gonna play this
this is the greatest just if you
[__] this is what I said I get
an argument all the time with my girl
about this [__]
Nicholas Cage greatest actor of all time
all right you know why he makes choices
he makes
he takes chances they're not all going
to be good
but because he does that it makes him
[__] amazing all right Nicholas Cage
is an amazing actor that has done some
bad movies
but if I but this is the he keeps coming
out with movies and I'm like all right
so he's the greatest
to take a chance and do this in a movie
is the most
donkey bold choice you could possibly
make he's got so many his balls are so
large that he just sometimes relaxes by
sitting on him
okay they're like one of those [__]
things that you can find in the toy
stores that you bounce on those are what
his balls are because of this
foreign
so he's in a car with three black guys
now it's important that he's white and
they're black because
you can tell Nicholas Cage God he's so
good look at his face just look at his
goddamn face in this [__] thing
that's money yeah hey what's up he wants
to
impress them
and this is just uh unreal unreal that
he does this dude
that's money yeah hey what's up
where's the fifteen thousand he just
[__]
by saying hey hey stop
dude
you don't get it man relax
did I not do what I said I was going to
do
yo man
relax
tell me again to relax
I'm not looking to beat you man
where's my money it's holding a gun on
him I'll get your money when tomorrow
where so good my place
give me a cut of the uncut dope
so I'm gonna pay you in money so good
this is interesting that's [__] man
what's that little man no man
chill out
here
takes the coke
now put that gun away before you kill
somebody
what's the gun away kill all of you and
then
this wasn't there's no way this was in
the script
to break it down
amazing
to the break of dawn baby
dude how he goes to the breaker Dome
baby uh so insecure but also so secure
bro Nicholas Cage I'll suck you off
straight up
then he goes into the [__] bar
to the [__] to this white guy and and
this is what he does oh don't [__]
[__] no [__] bets Terence yo
what's the matter don't you like a
little boy you don't pay your debts I
don't want to know you I can't afford it
ten grand five IO yeah five of Louisiana
right there sup
oh uh putting money in his pocket saying
sup
where'd you get this what are you my
priest it's right down here I got it
it's a six point spread oh [__]
stop
he's the best actor there I mean dude if
you don't think Nicholas Cage is the
there's a comment Nicolas Cage caged the
[__] out of this roll I love this man
when he says to The Brick of Dome baby
God he's [__] Full Throttle huh
Nicholas Cage is just so good I want to
meet him so bad that's the only guy I'd
probably geek out harder than when I met
Keanu Reeves
I don't know that's up there the two of
them are the best
different different Nicholas Cage I
genuinely think it's one of Grace actor
all time
uh
Keanu Reeves I think is one of the
greatest movie stars
uh but yeah man wow just [__] sup
what's up
hey
I'm jealous he did that now I can't do
it I gotta get in more of these [__]
movies so I could take [__] donkey
ball chances man
I need to take these donkey ball chances
man
just gotta get comfy